all right we're back at nat con and i am
joined by the senior editor of human
events and twitter warrior
i mean that in the best sense you you've
been just mauling people on twitter well
you know here's the thing jack did i say
your name you did yeah no no no no it's
it's it's not that
i go out with you know the big stick
just swinging it around you know but i
do carry it right in the in the
traditional teddy roosevelt sense yes
i carry the sickness i do not speak
softly but if some someone comes at me
like for example even max kennedy so
this was this was like so i don't like
getting too much into the twitter drama
but you have to explain what happened
here because it was such a perfect
decision and we're getting written up
everywhere yeah this is like of all the
things right and it's very simple yeah
candy had posted up this tweet
like a couple of days ago
based on a study and it was a report in
the hill.com about the study that it
said
that a ton of white college applicants
were lying about their ethnicity to
claim
minority status in order to get into
college and then if you dug into the
study which he had actually posted on
his own twitter account
that 70 77 percent of people who had
done this were then accepted by the
colleges
and a lot of people pointed out candy
you know doesn't this kind of fly in the
face of
your entire life's work right because
you claim there's systemic racism in the
opposite direction
than what the data you have presented to
us shows
so he deletes the tweet and then i i
just tweeted out that um you know he
deleted the tweet once it proved what
everybody kind of think that approves
like it disproved his entire existence
play out play out the thought there
again he does that kind of disprove and
then he claimed that i lied
and then he claimed that i lied and so i
just kept reposting his tweet over and
over and over
he goes into this huge meltdown and then
i use and if you're not on on twitter if
you're on social media
there's there's this phrase you say like
oh people would use it for trump all the
time they'd say we broke trump remember
that we broke trump and he's melting
down we broke him and lincoln project
would say this all the time oh we broke
trump so because he's spiraling out of
control and melting down right and which
i don't think he ever did but whatever
it was the slang and so i said i broke
kennedy because you could see this
meltdown of just you know tweet through
it man just tweet through it just tweet
through the ratio just tweet through the
ratios yeah so he's tweeting his fans
over at brock kennedy and then kind of
goes oh
you just used the word broke did you
know about the word broke and it has a
history of slavery and slaves being
broken by the slave masters and that's
what this person is i'm like first of
all dude i'm i'm polish um and it's also
i don't know if you know the etimoli of
the word slave but goes to slavic which
is pol but we're you know if we're
getting a word etymology we're not gonna
you know
you know my folks we didn't have the
colonies and the slaves that we've only
been here for like a minute in the u.s
um so no dude like and you even had um
liberals were going into his comments
saying like well i'm not a jackpot fan
but
dude that's not what he said right so i
don't like getting into the the twitter
and it's so darn great it's so dumb
but do you think there's any chance that
when one is so obvious like this one
like this was like man you just
everything you believe in you just
freaking reversed it and then delete it
do you think it could become culturally
important it's kind of like seeing that
jenga you know
puzzle right when they do the tower and
jenga and you just see that one piece
and you know right you know that that's
the one if i just pull that
done right so i pulled it
you know
and then and and we now shall see it
right and i don't think well i think
that people with people like kennedy he
could have by the way had the
intellectual honesty to say
you know this is an interesting data
point and i would love to see the study
if it was run a different way and
you know
maybe update my thinking but of course
he didn't do that right of course it
becomes no well these people are lying
and they're bad because they're lying
and that's and don't
have any discussion beyond that
whatsoever and i think that where we are
as a society right now because if you're
going to support a guy like candy who's
you know we all know he's using bad
research he's using data that flies in
the face of his own subpositions that
he's not rechecking his priors ever
because the griff must go on and so
unfortunately i think that given the
state of woke corporate america right
now and a lot of this is pushed with
these esg thing that i've been speaking
out against which is essentially a
corporate social credit score not
unreminiscent of what the ccp pushes for
their entire society we now have that
it's just that we do it for wall street
for some reason so i think that again it
serves a purpose the same idea
people will get on me and they say they
say jack why don't you call out all the
people that fly on private jets to go to
the carbon conference what about the
carbon footprint why they put it you
don't get it like you don't understand
the purpose of virtue signaling is the
signal right none of what they say
matters but what matters is the fact
that they said it and you are going to
catch up an entire swath of people
you'll be lost in those flowery words
and the language that's used and they're
not going to care they're absolutely not
good because they don't have to pay the
bill you have to pay the bill it's not
eat the rich it's actually eat the
middle class right you don't need to
work
peter till made an interesting point
last night that at these conferences
with davos and all these climate
conferences all these things that no one
is representing the individual it's
people that represent companies people
that represent large organizations ngos
governments but no one just represents
like the one human being who's trying to
just fend for their lives yeah and i
thought that was actually a pretty
interesting take that you have these
huge things which by the way i'm sure
you saw biden fell asleep at today it's
so important if only he had
purchased
a high-quality american-made pillow
did you even know you could one that may
be from
minnesota a place called mypillow.com
with promo composer up to 66 off joe
make sure that you get your order in now
the supply chains have been having some
issues but don't worry because this
doesn't have to come from overseas it's
american-made and by the way utilize
promo code poso no don't pay full
freight come on joe i'm doing this for
you you see how i handed you that one i
mean that was like silver platter stuff
but but this is the same thing with
these corporations that when they push
this off when they promote candy when
they give money for this it's not about
actually putting candy in a position of
power right it's just about saying that
they check the box and then they go off
and do whatever they want
is this really all about china you were
on my show maybe a month and a half ago
or something we talked a bit about this
but is this all really that this social
credit thing that you just mentioned is
just being ushered in china basically is
controlling all our board rooms whether
they know it or not and
we're slowly just going in that
direction well i think it's not
necessarily about
like i wouldn't say that china's behind
it put it that way and if people have
asked me that they say is china behind
all of this because we see the
authoritarianism yes and no right
they're behind it in the sense that
they created the initial
authoritarianism and when i worked in
shanghai and i was at the chamber of
commerce there and i was working in
international business and i would see
these congressional delegations and
business delegations and governors would
come through and they wouldn't say they
wouldn't come to china and say you know
you guys need to learn about bicameral
uh
democracy and a representative republic
and all this in two-party systems no no
no they came in and said
so when you want to build a maglev you
can just remove all these people from
your way
and then you just get the funding and
you have to order the bank to give you
the loan and it just happens wow that's
great how do we get that kind of system
back home and charlie munger has
basically come out and said this warren
buffett's partner a long time um really
the brains of the operation the oracle
of omaha and he's come out and said we
want the chinese financial system in the
united states so it's about adopting
that system of power and control which
to go back to what tia was saying it is
a form of central authority now it's not
maybe not necessarily formed solely in
the government but it's the
centralization of power and so the issue
with that as the founders and so many
people have spoken out against is this
is what leads to lethargy this is what
leads to abuses this is what leads to so
many issues and so you're seeing really
now a marriage of sort of the
woke corporate agenda with woke
political actors combined to give us the
system that we now
unfortunately are subject to so the
million dollar question that i've asked
everybody here i mean can we get through
this thing like how bad will it get
before we actually start turning this
thing around well i see some signs i see
some good times you know it's it's sort
of the frog in the pot right and so the
frog in the pot scenario
of course you know if you turn the heat
up too fast the frog jumps out well
we've got in america you know 315
million or so frogs and a very large you
know i guess cauldron and you know some
of those frogs are a little more
susceptible they say you know
feels like the water is getting warmer
feels like the water is getting warmer
and maybe five years ago in 2016 some of
us said i'm getting out i'm getting out
of this pot but other people said i'm
good i'm good i'm saying it but i was
listening to
the kyle rittenhouse jury selection i
love jury selection it's actually my
favorite part of trials because you get
to listen
to just sort of the average person just
a random swath of people as they were
talking and they were talking of course
about the riots that went down in
kenosha in 2020 horrific the burning the
arson all of it and one woman said you
know
my next door neighbor came to me and
said
that the american flag should never be
flown and asked if i would take it down
and the judge of course
not gonna leave something like that on
the table because he's a curious guy he
said well what did you do and she said i
didn't take it down i left it up and
went and bought a gun and this is just
this like older lady you know they can't
you can't see if it's off camera but i
said you know what when the pressure is
turned up like that when the water in
the cauldron becomes hot
people start getting switched on and
people start waking up to see what's
going on and i think you will see that
awakening be a response to this what
they call it the great reset right to be
a response to this because i think it's
just that people for a long time have
kind of been lulled into
we live in a very comfortable country
for the most part we really do we're the
wealthiest country in the world we're
one of the most uh powerful countries in
the world one of the most convenient
countries the world to live in but when
you start to make people uncomfortable
when people start to become uh they see
their systems breaking down they see law
and order breaking down then they start
getting awakened you see it happening in
kenosha from that lady who spoke out you
see it happening in loudoun county uh
when you look at one of the really
silver linings of covet and lockdowns as
crazy as they were and as awful as covid
was people started to actually look over
the shoulder in those zoom classrooms to
see what was going on yeah and you've
got loudoun county which is like a
liberal democrat area switched on
screaming at the teachers
and all it took was actually finding out
what was going on and so i do actually
have more hope for the system because
my i don't put my
faith in the government or in these
systems number one i put it in god but
number two i put it in the american
people and i believe that the people of
this country are still the same
descendants of people that decided to
come from other situations that they
were involved in and take that risk and
say you know what i think there is a
better land beyond the horizon and if
these are the rules of the road let's
figure it out work here build this land
as our home
and i think we can get back to that i
should let you go with that because it
was a beautiful closet wasn't that good
it was a beautiful closer it was nice
but i got one more for you actually
related to that all right because you
mentioned god and part of this
conference is how do we take traditional
say religious conservatives how do we
take the disaffected liberals how do we
take the libertarians how do we take the
trumpers and the whole thing and how can
we piece this freaking monster this
frankenstein together do you think it
can hold i mean that really has been the
theme here it's what i think is the
future if guys like us are going to
survive but what it is what it is is
that there's there's a
there is a frankenstein's monster right
and it's it's kendy's monster and it's
critical race theory monster that i
think everyone from these various
different nodes and factions and tribes
have all realized is just kind of
screwing everything up and so
you know i think that on one hand you
know you've got like a conservative
catholic like myself you know who would
say all right you know we need to end
this but you might also want someone in
the room to
be able to say all right but we don't
necessarily want to institute a catholic
integralist monarchy in the united
states let's stick with the pluralism
let's let's go with the rules of the
road and i say all right fine fine i'll
concede that for now yeah for now for
now
for now it's very very honest of you too
well that's what it's all about that's
what we're trying to figure out here
good seeing a man good to see if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell